สวัสดีค่ะครูนี้สวัสดีครับครูหญิงสวัสดี
นักเรียนทุกคนด้วยนะครับสวัสดีค่ะนัก
เรียนนะคะอ่ะเดี๋ยวเรามาเขียนวันที่เนาะ
วันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้ครับวันศุกร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 26 ครับเดือนอะไร
คะเดือนสิงหาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2022 ครับ
ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูนิด
ตอนนี้เนี่ย 8 โมง 59 นาทีตอนเช้านะครับ
แล้วเมืองที่ครูหญิงอยู่ตอนนี้กี่โมงครับ
เมืองที่คุยอยู่ก็ 9 โมง
59 นาทีค่ะ
แต่ว่าอีก 1 นาทีเนี่ยของครูนิคก็จะ 9
โมงน้องของครูหญิงก็ 10 โมง
ก็ไม่ขนาดนั้นนะคะ
เวลาคนไทยตอบว่าไม่ขนาดนั้นก็คือจริงๆ
แล้วเราไม่ค่อยทำนะคะเพราะว่าจะถามเรื่อง
อะไรก็ได้แบบผู้หญิงชอบออกกำลังกายไหมก็
ไม่ขนาด
คือเวลาพูดว่าไม่ขนาดนั้นมันก็จะเหมือน
กับจริงๆก็ถ้าสำหรับคุณนิคเนี่ยก็คือ
เหมือนเป็นการบอกแบบสุภาพว่าไม่ทำไม่ทำ
แต่คนไทยจะชอบพูดให้ฟังดูเหมือนแบบก็คงทำ
นิดหน่อยแหละ
จริงๆแล้วก็คือ
1% เท่านั้น
แต่ว่าคือผู้หญิงไม่ได้ชอบทำบุญนะคะแต่
ตอนเด็กๆอ่ะตอนเด็กๆนะแบบด้วยความที่เรา
ไม่ได้อยู่กรุงเทพฯนะคะเราอยู่ต่าง
จังหวัดอย่างนี้ก็คือถามว่าเราจะไปทำบุญ
ไหมเราเรียกว่าเราไปวัดละกันคือการไปวัด
ก็รู้สึกว่าได้บุญแล้วอ่ะรู้สึกเป็นคนดี
ก็
จริงๆแล้วเนี่ยส่วนตัวคุณนิดก็ไม่ใช่คน
ที่ทำบุญบ่อยคือเหมือนอย่างถ้าเทียบกับ
ที่บ้านคุณนี้ยังพ่อแม่คุณนิดเนี่ยจะไป
วัดทุกเทศกาล
เหมือนกันเหมือนกันค่ะ
ทอดกฐินน่ะทอดกฐิน
ทอดกฐินเขาจะเรียกว่ายังไงทอดกฐินกับผ้า
ป่านี่มันเหมือนกันไหม
มันคล้ายๆกันไหมคะแต่ว่าทอดกฐินเนี่ยมัน
ต้องหลังออกพรรษาก็คือหลังแบบเดือนที่ 10
แล้วอ่ะเดือนตุลาคมค่ะเขาก็จะมีทอดกฐิน
แต่ว่าทอดกฐินที่บ้านครูหญิงอ่ะเหมือนเขา
จะมีการทำอาหารด้วย
ในวัดอ่ะค่ะแล้วก็เหมือนเอาเงินที่ทุกคน
มาทำบุญเนี่ยให้กับวัด
ไปช่วย
หรือเอาบริจาค
แม่ครูนิ้งเนี่ยไม่เคยพลาด
นักเรียนอาจจะเคยเห็นไหมว่าที่มันเป็นถัง
สีเหลืองๆ
เออแล้วก็มีเงินเสียบอยู่อ่ะค่ะเดี๋ยววัน
นี้อาจจะเปิดให้ดูก็ได้มีเงินเนี่ยเสียบ
อยู่นั่นแหละค่ะคือทอดผ้าป่าหรือว่าทอด
กฐินแบบคนไทยก็คือเป็นเหมือน
เป็นการทำบุญโดยใช้เงินน่ะเพราะว่าส่วน
ใหญ่เวลาที่เราไปวัดเราไม่ได้เอาเงินไปทำ
บุญไปส่วนใหญ่นะคะเราจะทำอาหารเหมือนทำ
อาหารเลี้ยงพระ
มันก็จะเป็นแบบนี้ครับเขาก็จะเอาเงินไป
ใส่ให้เหมือนไปเป็นต้นไม้เป็นพุ่มแบบนี้
เนาะ
[เพลง]
ว่ามันไม่ใช่ว่าเอาเงินไปใส่ตู้จดมันก็
ต่อไปทำบุญแบบอื่นได้ว่าให้อาหารพระหรือ
เอาของใช้ให้พระแบบนี้ครับ
ซึ่งส่วนใหญ่คนไทยจะเวลาไปวัดทำบุญเนี่ย
จะใช้แบบเอาของไปมากกว่าใช่ไหมคะเงิน
เนี่ยนิดหน่อยอาจจะบริษัท 20 บาททำไมไม่
ค่อยไม่ค่อยได้ทำบุญด้วยเงิน
ใช่คือที่ถามคุณหญิงเกี่ยวกับทำบุญเนี่ย
เพราะว่าแค่อยากรู้ว่า
เพราะปกติอ่ะถ้าพูดง่ายๆเวลาคนไทยอยากทำ
บุญเขาก็จะไปวัดใช่ไหมครับ
ก็หาวัดไม่ยากมันมีเยอะแต่ต่างประเทศ
เนี่ยครูหญิงเคยเห็นวัดที่ต่างประเทศไหม
คือผู้หญิงเคยเห็นแต่ไม่รู้ว่านี่คือวัด
ทำไมครับ
ไม่ใช่วัดของไทยนะคะแต่มันก็พูดเหมือนกัน
นะศาสนาพุทธเหมือนกันแต่พูดมีหลายหลายแบบ
ใช่ไหมคะอันนี้น่าจะเป็นสไตล์แบบทิเบตนะ
คือที่บอกว่าไม่เพราะว่าครูหญิงเนี่ย
กำลังเดินผ่านใช่ไหมคะแล้วก็แบบมีคนชี้
บอกว่านี่นะวัดไปวัดไหม
นี่ไงนี่ไงวัดคุณหญิงก็เลยหันไป
เนี่ยนะวัดคือมันเหมือนเป็นเป็นคือถ้า
บ้านเราจะเรียกว่าเป็นทาวน์เฮ้าส์แล้วโซน
นั้นมันคือทาวน์เฮ้าส์อ่ะค่ะมันก็จะมีตรง
นี้มุมเนี่ยทาวน์เฮ้าส์ทาวน์เฮ้าส์
ทาวน์เฮ้าส์แต่ทาวน์เฮ้าส์นี้คือวัดเพราะ
ว่าผู้หญิงมองขึ้นไปข้างบนอ๋อมันมีหลังคา
ที่ทรงคล้ายๆวัดก็แบบทำไมวัดไม่อยู่ใกล้ๆ
กับบ้านคนอย่างนี้อ่ะ
มันก็มันก็เป็นแบบนั้นเพราะว่าคุณนิจำได้
ว่าคุณนิเคยไปวัดที่ต่างประเทศคือครั้ง
แรกที่คุณนิกไปเนี่ยคือตอนที่คุณนิกอยู่
ที่ซิดนีย์ที่ออสเตรเลียคุณก็แบบเอออยาก
ไปวัดแต่คือจริงๆคนนี้ก็พอจะรู้แล้วล่ะ
ว่า
มันจะไม่ได้เหมือนวัดที่ไทยเพราะคุณนึก
เคยดูวีดีโอหรือเคยดูเหมือนกับรายการทีวี
ที่เขาบอกว่าไปวัดที่ต่างประเทศแล้วมันก็
จะเป็นเหมือนตึกธรรมดา
แต่ส่วนใหญ่ก็จะเป็นที่วัดที่อยู่ในเมือง
ใหญ่ๆนะเพราะว่าเขาไม่ได้มีที่ใหญ่ๆ
เหมือนบ้านเราที่จะทำเป็นวัดกว้างๆใช่
แล้วบางที่เนี่ยเขาเหมือนกับเช่า
ใช่แล้วมันก็จะถ้ายิ่งต่างประเทศเนาะถ้า
เวลาเราจะต้องเช่าที่หรือเช่าตึกเนี่ย
ยิ่งใหญ่มันก็ยิ่งแพง
ค่าเช่าค่าเช่าเนี่ยมันแพงมากๆใช่เขาก็
เลยว่าโอเคแล้วอีกอย่างนึงเพราะว่าวัด
เนี่ยเขาจะไม่ได้มีรายได้เหมือน
ถ้าเราเช่าตึกเพื่อเปิดบริษัทมันก็เขาก็
คงคิดว่าเออก็เอาแบบง่ายๆก็ได้
ครับก็แบบให้พอเข้าไปข้างในก็จะมีพระ
พุทธรูปให้คนเนี่ยไปวัดสมัยไปไหว้พระนั่ง
สมาธิสบายใจหรือไปทำบุญคือครูนิคเนี่ยเคย
ไปวัดในต่างประเทศใช่ไหมคะแล้วมีพระไหมมี
พระครับ
เดี๋ยวพรุ่งนี้จะเอารูปให้ดูอันนี้ครับ
เป็นวัดที่ซิดนีย์มันเป็นแบบนี้นะก็ดูจาก
ข้างนอกก็ยัง
เดาได้นะว่าเป็นวัด
มันจะเป็นแบบนี้
คือคุณเดาได้ว่าเป็นวัดเพราะว่าเดี๋ยว
กำลังหาภาพที่มันใหญ่ๆเพราะว่าที่วัดด้าน
หน้ามันเหมือนกับเป็นจากใช่ไหมกงจักรค่ะ
เราก็เลยรู้ว่าอ๋อวัดไทยเพราะใครเอาคงจาก
มาวางเหมือนกับเป็นให้บ้านมันสวยๆอ่ะใช่
ผู้หญิงกำลังจะพูดเลยว่าแต่ว่าฝรั่งอาจจะ
เอามาตกแต่งบ้านก็ได้นะ
ถ้าเป็นรูปปั้นน่ะยังโอเคนะเหมือนรูปปั้น
แบบเทพอะไรอย่างนี้ครับที่เป็นเนี่ยที่
ไม่รู้เพราะภาพมันไม่ใหญ่มากที่อยู่ตรง
ข้างๆแบบนี้ก็โอเคใช่แต่เนี่ยครับคือวัด
ที่ซิดนีย์เป็นแบบนี้
[เพลง]
เราไม่ได้เห็นกงจักรแบบเดินผ่านๆเนี่ยก็
นึกว่าเป็นบ้านได้นะคะไม่ได้รู้สึกว่านี่
คือวัดเลย
ก็ส่วนใหญ่อ่ะครับวัดเนี่ยต่างประเทศก็จะ
ประมาณนี้หรือจะเป็นตึกแถวธรรมดาก็มีคุณ
นิดเคยที่ซิดนีย์เหมือนกันเคยไปวัดจีน
แล้วว่าจีนเออลองดูเพราะในหัวเราเนี่ยเรา
คิดแล้วว่าเออต้องเหมือนวัดมังกรเนอะแดงๆ
เออใช่พอไปถึงอ่ะครับจริงๆมันเหมือนกับ
เป็นแบบเป็นทาวน์เฮ้าส์ธรรมดามองจากข้าง
นอกพอเปิดประตูเข้าไปก็จะเห็นเหมือนกับ
เป็นเจ้าที่แล้วก็มีแค่จุดให้ไหว้เหมือน
เจ้าแม่กวนอิมหรือจุดธูปแค่นั้น
แต่ว่าข้างนอกคือดูไม่รู้เลย
ใช่ๆคือเขาก็จะมีป้ายบอกนะว่าเหมือนกับ
เป็นวัดจีนแต่ถ้าไม่มีป้ายเนี่ยเรานึกว่า
เป็นบ้านธรรมดา
ถ้าเราไม่ได้อ่านป้ายด้วยละกัน
แต่ว่า
วัดอย่างวัดในต่างประเทศเนี่ยถึงแม้จะแบบ
ดูลักษณะข้างนอกอ่ะค่ะมันไม่เหมือนวัดแต่
คนที่เขาบอกข้างในก็มีพระแต่เราสามารถไป
ทำบุญได้เหมือนวัดที่ไทยเลยไหมคะ
เหมือนกันเพราะว่าเขาก็จะมีบอกนะว่าวัด
เปิดตอนนี้ถึงตอนนี้ถ้าจำไม่ผิดคิดว่า
เปิดถึง 5 โมงเย็น
ก็คล้ายๆไทยอ่ะคล้ายๆกันคือเราจะไป
ปกติเนี่ยคุณนิคจะไปตอนเช้าเพราะว่าเขาก็
จะมีเหมือนแม่ครัวแล้วก็มีคนไทยที่มาช่วย
ทำอาหารให้พระ
ครับเขาจะมีเหมือนกับเป็นคนที่ทำงานตรง
นั้นเขาก็จะมาช่วยทำอาหารเพราะว่าพระต้อง
ฉัน
เวลาคือสำหรับพระที่กินข้าว
ก็ทำอาหารให้พระครับแล้วก็จะมี
ส่วนจริงๆเขาก็จะทำเหมือนกับเป็นอาหารเพล
อาหารเพลก็คือเหมือนกับเป็นมื้อเที่ยง
ก็คือเป็นมื้อที่ 2 ที่พระอาจารย์ได้
ก็จะมาทำการแล้วก็มีสวดมนต์แล้วหลังจาก
นั้นเนี่ยก็ยังไปได้ครับก็จะทำถ้าอยากจะ
คนไทยก็จะเรียกว่าเหมือนกับทำสังฆทานเนาะ
ทำสังฆทานก็คือเหมือนกับเราไปซื้อของใช้
แล้วก็เอามาให้พระเหมือนกับเอามา
ถ้าที่ไทยเนี่ยก็จะเป็นถังสีเหลืองๆนะคะ
เป็นสังฆทานซึ่งมันง่ายไงมันจะสะดวก
แต่ว่าที่ต่างประเทศก็มีไหมจริงๆก็มีแต่
ว่ามันหาไม่ง่ายคนไทยก็จะแค่ไปซื้อของ
แล้วก็หากระดาษมาห่อหรือไปซื้อเป็นตะกร้า
แล้วเอามาใส่ให้มันดูเหมือนกับเป็น
สังฆทานแต่ก็อาจจะเป็นแค่สีขาวๆแบบนี้ก็
ได้ครับ
ใช่ก็เหมือนเป็นของจำเป็นใช่ไหมคะที่แบบ
พระท่านต้องใช้ก็เหมือนเรานั่นแหละ
มันก็จะเป็นแบบนี้จริงๆถ้าวัดต่างประเทศ
อ่ะครับ
ถ้า
มันจะมีที่คุณนิคคุณนิคไม่เคยไปแต่ว่าพี่
สาวคุณนิคเนี่ยเขาไปก็จะเป็นวัดที่
สวิตเซอร์แลนด์เนี่ยคือถ้ามันอยู่นอก
เมืองเขามีพื้นที่เยอะเขาก็ทำเป็นเหมือน
วัด
ในประเทศไทยได้
สีเหลืองๆทองๆแบบสวยๆใหญ่ๆแล้วแบบเราเห็น
แล้วเรารู้เลยว่าโอ้วัดไทยแน่นอนใช่ๆแต่
ก็คือมันก็จะไม่ได้สีเหลืองทองแบบ
แต่ก็มันจะเป็นแบบนี้ครับอันนี้คุณนิดคิด
ว่าน่าจะใช่ฉันมันก็จะเป็นแบบนี้เลยครับ
เดี๋ยวคนนี้จะเอารูปให้ดู
เพราะว่า
มันก็ดูเข้าใจได้นะครูนี้ว่านี่คือวัด
ด้วยความที่แบบลักษณะแบบนี้นี่คือวัดแน่
นอนก็ถ้าเมืองนั้นเนี่ยมีที่ที่อยู่ข้าง
นอกเมืองเยอะๆเขาก็จะทำแบบนี้เหมือนกัน
ครับ
[เพลง]
ใช่ค่ะเพราะว่าคิดว่าหลายๆคือด้วยความที่
คนไทยส่วนใหญ่ศาสนาพุทธน้องเวลาที่ไปอยู่
ต่างประเทศประเทศแล้วประเทศที่เราไปอยู่
หรือว่าเมืองที่เราไปอยู่เนี่ยมีวัดหรือ
ว่าไม่มีไม่รู้นะแต่อย่างผู้หญิงมาอย่าง
นี้ค่ะก็จะหาว่าเมืองที่เราอยู่เนี่ยมี
วัดไทยไหมคือเราก็แบบบางครั้งเราก็อยากไป
ใช่ไหมแบบบางทีอาจส่วนใหญ่เราไปวัดมีทั้ง
เรื่องดีใจก็ไปวัดได้มีเรื่องไม่สบายใจก็
ไปวัดได้ไงมันจะรู้สึกเหมือนอยู่บ้าน
เหมือนโดยเฉพาะถ้าเราอยู่ต่างประเทศนะคะ
เพราะว่า
สงกรานต์คนไทยก็ไปวัดใช่ไหมเหมือนคุณยิ่ง
บอกว่าคุณแม่คุณนิคเนี่ยทุกเทศกาลน่ะไป
วัด
ก็คุณก็คิดอย่างนั้นเหมือนกันแต่ว่าจะ
เรียกว่าอะไรนะ
คุณนี้ก็ยังคุณยังไม่รู้ว่าแถวบ้านคุณนิด
เนี่ยมีแถวเมืองใกล้ๆคุณนิดนึงมีวัดไหม
ตอนนี้กำลังดูใน Google
คือมันเพราะว่าเมืองที่คุณนิคอยู่จริงๆนะ
มีคนลาวเยอะ
มากกว่าคนไทยแล้วลองดูใน Google เนี่ยวัด
เนี่ยก็จะเป็นวัดลาวก็ถือว่าวัดไทยเรา
เหมือนกันเหมือนกันนะเหมือนกันแค่ว่าตัว
หนังสืออาจจะไม่เหมือนกันแค่นั้นเอง
เพราะจริงๆเหมือนถ้าเป็นวัดลาวเนี่ยถ้า
ภาคเหนือเนี่ยเขาก็จะมีวัดที่คล้ายๆกับ
วัดเราเยอะคุณนี้ก็เคยไป
อันนี้แบบอันนี้คือ
อันนี้ของที่ผู้หญิงเห็นมันก็ไม่เหมือน
วัดนะคะคุณนิแอนเดี๋ยวให้นักเรียนดู
ว่าเขามีวัดพุทธรังสีเนี่ยหลายประเทศมาก
คนนี้ก็เพิ่งรู้เหมือนกันก็จะอยู่ตาม
เมืองแห่งใหญ่ที่คุณนิเคยได้ยินน่ะนะใช่
ก็น่าจะอยู่แบบเมืองที่คนไทยไปอยู่เยอะ
ใช่ไหมคะอย่างซิดนีย์อย่างนี้คนไทยอยู่
เยอะแต่ว่าถ้าอย่างอเมริกาก็อาจจะเป็นพวก
อะไรนะคะแคลิฟอร์เนียไหมใช่ Los  ange
มีชุมชนคนไทยคนลาวซึ่งคิดว่าศาสนาพุทธใน
ไทยกับในลาวนี่คือเหมือนกันเหมือนกันครับ
เหมือนกัน
นะว่ามันอยู่ใกล้บ้านคุณก็ดูท่าจะเป็นวัด
ใหญ่
[เพลง]
ใช่ไหมคะ
แล้วก็ก็จะเป็นแบบนี้ครับ
แต่คุณไม่เห็นใหญ่มากเลยใช่
ค่ะก็จะมีเป็นเมืองที่มีพื้นที่เลยวัดก็
จะสร้างได้ใหญ่ได้
ข้างนอกเนี่ยก็อย่างนี้ครับ
จริงๆที่เหมือนเวลาเราไปต่างจังหวัดเนาะ
เพราะจริงๆถ้าในกรุงเทพฯก็ไม่มีที่แบบนี้
ใช่ค่ะวัดในกรุงเทพฯก็ไม่ได้ใหญ่มาก
เหมือนกันเนี่ยแบบเมื่อก่อนโรงเรียนครู
หญิงเป็นโรงเรียนวัดอ่ะก็วัดโรงเรียนอยู่
ด้วยกันใหญ่นะแต่เป็นวัดแล้วก็โรงเรียน
เนี่ยอยู่ด้วยกันคือของคุณนิดเนี่ยก็เป็น
โรงเรียนวัดแต่ว่าเขาจะเหมือนมีกำแพงกัน
ว่าโอเคตรงนี้เป็นโรงเรียนแล้วก็แค่ข้าม
กำแพงไปก็เป็นวัดละแต่ก็เป็นวัดที่ไม่ได้
ใหญ่มากก็คืออาจจะมี
แล้วก็มี
ศาลาประมาณ 2 หรือ 3 แค่นั้นใช่เพราะว่า
แบบว่าในเมืองเนาะก็คือด้วยความที่เหมือน
คุณหญิงบอกเขาว่าวัดเนี่ยมันเป็นอะไรที่
ถ้าเรารู้สึกว่าเมืองที่เราอยู่เนี่ยมี
วัดไทยด้วยสมมุติเราอยู่ที่ไหนก็ได้นะคะ
เราก็รู้สึกแบบสบายใจอ่ะเพราะว่าอย่างที่
บ้านหรือว่าในประเทศไทยหลายๆหมู่บ้านน่ะ
ถ้าเป็นต่างจังหวัดอย่างนี้ค่ะอย่างน้อย
อ่ะต้องมีวัด 1 วัดอยู่
เพราะว่านักเรียนอาจจะเคยได้ยินว่าแบบเออ
คนไทยกิจกรรมทุกอย่างในชีวิตมันจะเกี่ยว
ข้องกับวัดอยู่แล้วก็อาจจะคล้ายๆกับศาสนา
คริสต์ศาสนาอิสลามของนักเรียนใช่ไหมคะก็
จะมีโบสถ์มีมัสยิดด้วย
จริงๆ
โบสถ์ของศาสนาคริสต์อย่างนี้คุณนี้จะส่วน
ตัวคุณนิดชอบชอบโบสถ์เพราะว่า
อย่างในกรุงเทพฯอ่ะครับถ้าโบสถ์ศาสนา
คริสต์เนี่ยคุณนิคชอบเพราะว่าตึกมันสวย
ใช่ๆๆค่ะ
มันใหญ่มาก
ไม่รู้ว่าคือคุณนี้ก็เคยไปเที่ยวที่
ไอซ์แลนด์แล้วก็เขามีโบสถ์แล้วเป็นโบสถ์
ที่สวยมาก
[เพลง]
คืออย่างยุโรปเนอะเหมือนยุโรปเนี่ยอย่าง
หลายๆประเทศในยุโรปเราสามารถที่จะเข้า
โบสถ์ฟรีคือบทแบบสวยๆค่ะแต่ผู้หญิงเคยไป
อังกฤษเหมือนต้องจ่ายเงินน่ะโบสถ์
จะถ่ายรูปอ่ะค่ะเหมือนต้องใส่เงินไหมยัง
ไม่เคยไปเที่ยวที่อังกฤษแต่ว่าที่
ฝรั่งเศสก็เป็นเหมือนกันในปารีสถ้าเกิด
เราอยากไปโบสถ์ใหญ่ๆที่เหมือนจะมี
ประวัติศาสตร์ยาวๆนะก็จะต้องเสียเงิน
เพราะว่าเขาคิดว่าคนเข้าไปดูเยอะแล้วของ
บางอย่าง
หรือพื้นที่
คนเข้าไปเยอะๆแล้วไปเหยียบเนี่ยมันจะต้อง
มีการดูแลดูแลไม่งั้นก็เลยจะต้องเอาเงิน
มาทำตรงนั้นต้องเก็บเงินไม่อย่างนั้นถ้า
คนเข้ามาเยอะๆสภาพของโบสถ์มันก็จะค่อยๆ
เสื่อมลงเสื่อมลง
18 ปอนด์มั้งตอนนั้นน่ะเราก็รู้สึกว่า
ไม่เป็นไรเราดูข้างนอกแล้วกันข้างนอกก็
สวยแต่สวยมาก
คือดังอ่ะ
เป็น categoral นี่แหละค่ะ
จริงๆว่าชื่ออะไรอันนี้ครับไอซ์แลนด์นะ
ที่เป็นโบสถ์คุณนิดชอบมาก
คือถ่ายรูปถ้าอยากถ่ายรูปแบบสูงๆทั้งหมด
เนี่ยถ้าอยู่หน้าโบสถ์อ่ะคือต้องเอา
โทรศัพท์วางพื้นเลยอ่ะเพราะว่ามันสูงจริง
ๆ
เออสวยค่ะสวยใช่เนาะก็คิดว่าเหมือนกันนะ
คะเวลาที่นักเรียนเนี่ยเห็นโบสถ์ทุกวัน
ทุกวันเนาะนักเรียนก็โอเคชินแต่ว่านัก
เรียนมาเห็นวัดที่ไทยนักเรียนก็จะรู้สึก
ว่าแบบ
ว้าวสวยมากแต่ผู้หญิงกับคุณนี้คือคนไทย
อ่ะค่ะเราเห็นตั้งแต่เด็กอ่ะเราก็รู้สึก
เข้าวัด
ใช่ๆผู้หญิงก็เหมือนกันครูนี้แบบ
สวยมากอ่ะพ่อเรารู้สึกว่ามันแตกต่างจาก
วัดของเรามากๆไงวัดเรามันแบบสีทองสีขาว
อะไรอย่างนี้แต่โบสถ์เขาจะดูเป็นสีแบบสี
ปูนใช่สีปูนขาวหรือบางที่ก็จะเป็นสีขาว
อาจจะไม่มีทองๆเหมือนอย่างของวัดไทย
เราก็เลยมาคุยให้ฟังนะคะเกี่ยวกับแบบเออ
วัดที่ไทยเนี่ยเราชินอยู่แล้วเนาะแต่เวลา
เราไปต่างประเทศเนี่ยวัดที่ต่างประเทศ
เป็นยังไง
มีไหม
บางทีก็ไม่คิดว่าเป็นวัด
[เพลง]
ไหมใหญ่หรือเปล่าเหมือนที่ไทยไหมหรือว่า
เหมือนที่ครูนิดให้ดูก็คอมเมนต์บอกเราได้
หมดแล้วเดี๋ยวเรามาเจอกันใหม่ในวีดีโอ
หน้านะคะสวัสดีค่ะ